it's gonna be really exciting tonight
because it's the last round of Monday
night mayhem so for the first month the
tournament's gomen going pretty good
seems like we're gonna get some new
participants tonight which is fun so
whatever you see up here tonight that's
what the openings going to be and yeah
it's fun it's an unrated tournament
because it's thematic so you can talk
you could be on your cell phone if
you're new to chess you can say what
should I do here what's going on and you
know you can talk to people so it's kind
of fun it's just a fun little tournament
and the prize this month is the free
entry to the Metro class championship so
somebody's going to get an entry fee
worth about 50 bucks so that'll be
exciting and today for our opening I
picked one of the most popular openings
in all of chess so many people have
requested it so tonight we're going to
do the Sicilian night ourf as requested
by Michael Phillips Paul Morphy Mara
Sarkar Frederic PJ rutkowski the boss
minecraft PvP and many others so when
it's that popular you just have to do it
you got to give the people what they
want so today we're going to do the
night ourf okay we'll put the first few
moves on the board white is getting
ready if it gets another turn he'll play
d4 so the Sicilian is the most
aggressive way for black to combat this
opening and all right so white will
develop is night and there's several
moves here but we're going to be looking
at a d6 Sicilian in this game the point
of d6 is to control you 5 so you can
play Knight f6 so White's idea was to
play d4 black takes white gets to take
back with a knight now and white will
often try to play C 4 if you just wait
for example if you just play g6 maybe
why don't play c4 so the most common
move for black is to attack the pawn and
force white to put a knight in front of
the pond and okay so here we go this is
our position and the move we're going to
look at tonight and there's there's a
few here you know you can play e6 that's
fine g6 we've had a look at in the past
but today we're looking at the knight or
a six so if you've never seen this you
might be thinking wait why is this so
popular
why have all of like the best players
ever in several world champions garry
kasparov has played this an on plays it
a lot to Paul off and there's so many
people that they play this opening why
do they do it why did they move their
pond on the side of the board and to
understand why they might do that we
need to understand the consequences in
this position of the move e5 this is a
move that black sometimes likes to play
in these openings and so on the night
off that's what he's going to aim for
and all right if white is compliant then
you know he just he just moves his
knight back or something not necessarily
the best move at all
then what black will just get sort of a
normal position but he you know white
has a much more testing move in this
position so if you do play this with
with white and you get this position
there's just one move you need to know
here to get a big advantage and that's
Bishop to b5 check welcome and ok after
this move there's not really a great way
for black to to meet this check so we'll
just take a quick look at some of these
to see how you can get an advantage
early if they block with a bishop I mean
the other option is like a block with a
knight you can get a nice advantage by
trading the bishops which is greatly in
White's favor because the key
strategical battle in this position is
going to be over the d5 square that's a
weakness that black created when he
played a 5 and we'll take a look at E 5
later and try to understand the pros and
cons why would somebody do that create a
weakness what's what's the benefits of
black we'll have a look at that but here
since you got rid of the light squared
bishop s-- y he gets a very pleasant
position just after retreating the
knight and he's going to castle and keep
control over this square and okay just
to go a few moves farther if okay white
this is also a typical way he's going to
exchange the knight on f6 that way he
gets more control over d5 so we'll just
put an example on the board and this is
sort of a dream position for white he's
often trying to get a really good night
versus a bad Bishop that's the minor
piece ending that the white really wants
to get in this so if you trade off all
the pieces and you're left with that
knight on d5 and a dark squared Bishop
they can't touch it then you're playing
the opening right so and it's also
interesting if we look here does
that's not as good but it's interesting
when we compare it to a line in the
future here and that's Knight to f5
which okay that seems like a pretty good
move right we're eyeing some of these
key squares here making it hard for him
develop the bishop but in this position
black has a little little tactical move
he can take on e4 and okay so if you
recapture I'm going to take your knight
and I just want a pawn but white can do
a desperado here he can grab this pawn
with check and okay after these moves
things are looking pretty decent for
white
you know what's where's black going to
castle but he does get to move d5 in and
when you're playing black and you're
playing the knight or if this is the
move you're always trying to achieve
you're trying to get the move d5 in to
get rid of your weakness and alright
well you can just retreat but there's a
tactical move we got a lot of people now
so I'll that's the audience does anyone
see the tactical move that white can
play here is Bishop to h6 what's going
on you're hanging your bishop I will no
because what does white play here yeah
right so we we fork the Queen in the
king so that's a tricky move that is
possible in this position and this is
mostly just an example of the kinds of
thing that can happen so black will
instead castle and okay you can take
this guy
but after we'll just make a couple more
moves here in a position like this white
really isn't thinking that he has any
really large advantage in this position
so all right it's true that this King is
a little bit exposed but the center is
really nice for black and it's it is a
roughly equal position so that's why
most people if we go back in this
position
they don't prefer to put their knight on
f5 you know they just go back and you a
good position and we'll compare that to
a different line because we'll go back
to this position for a second and this
time we'll block with a knight well in
this position Knight to f5 is a really
good move and it comes with a threat
it's nice that the knight can't be taken
and okay we got two pieces aiming at d6
so we're already threatening to win upon
so the most common move here is a six
and in order to save time we can trade
here and black has to take back with the
Queen which is you know a little bit
undesirable he wishes he could take with
a bishop but then his deep on would fall
with check so the Queen will take and
now alright there's there's several ways
one is you can just put your knight here
and control d5 but perhaps even more
testing is the move Bishop to g5 and
alright is this the same situation can
black take on e4 here now if he takes on
e4 we'll throw the same check in he'll
take back will take back but now the
position is a little bit different the
Queen here is a little bit awkward and
the benefit of having this Knight here
are the bishop here is that sometimes
we'll play Knight f6 check and you'll
have to take with this bishop so he can
the best move perhaps objectively is
just to Castle and let this pawn fall
which means you shouldn't play this way
is black but if you try to play more
like a human Knight to d5
sorry pawn to d5 okay we get this check
in so now we see the importance of
having that bishop there and all right
so we put an attack on the rook and they
castle will just go over a few more
moves here White's best move is that
Queen f3 and alright he's going to put
his Queen here and you know and try to
checkmate you but okay so we'll look at
this position so black has to stop
checkmate
how can he do it right so queen g4 and
alright we're just throwing this sort of
as an example this isn't the feature of
the lecture here but all right something
like work d1 and if black ever trades
this is going to be really bad for him
yeah so why does have doubled pawns
that's true but okay I'm going to put my
rook up here I'm going to bring my other
rook over here and I'm gonna have a lot
of pressure on your H pawn and if I ever
take that and I get a rook here you
might be in a lot of trouble so this
would be really really bad for for black
okay so we can kind of see that all
right we need to in this position
control the b5 square because we don't
want a bishop going there sometimes we
don't want a knight going there and
that's why you know over the years as
we've learned in theory has evolved
a lot of people have went to a six and
if you're in a database and you just hit
the top moves and everything you're
going to end up in this position because
this is the most common way to play all
right what's up Scott and all right so
we'll we'll take a look at it here and
for white there's so many moves here if
you just play a random legal move it's
probably theory because it's been played
so much there's hundreds of thousands of
games people have tried all sorts of
things to get an advantage for a long
time the most popular move was Bishop to
g5 which I recommend looking at if you
want the really really sharp positions
and some of the craziest things that can
happen in chess happen in these lines
but we won't go over that tonight
tonight we're going to go over the
English attack because I think it's not
only is it really popular still at the
Grand Master level it's if you watch
people at the club whenever they play
the night or if this is what I see a lot
so I think this is important for a club
player so we'll take a look at this also
I mean there's so many moves Bishop to
e2 is a move this is the classical
variation ra4 is a move very popular
right now at the highest level is g3
with this fianchetto variation and Tata
Steel will be over by the time you're
watching this at home but right now it's
ongoing and that the night or if has
been played twice in that tournament and
both people prefer g3 in this position
so you see this a lot at the highest
level it's becoming quite popular and
often times when they play g3 the later
play h3 and g4 which is why sometimes
people like to in this position play h3
so this is the Adams attack and the
reason you're not super grandmasters is
because you play in the center too much
so you got to play a six you know you
got to play h3 and it's funny that you
know both people are playing on the
sides but yeah this is quite a quite a
popular approach and there's even
crazier ways to play g4 you can put your
rook on g1 and then okay you can try to
play g4 so all sorts of things have been
played the most common that I see at
least around here is the English attack
and all right White's plan is similar to
the Yugoslavia attack and the dragon
he's going to you know protect his pawn
and he's going
starting to have a Lynch and he's going
to go attack the black King and he's
going to be thinking about checkmate
also he's going to castle the other way
and it's both people are going to be
attacking each other so we'll get some
really sharp crazy stuff today
now the most common move is a five so
that's going to be the focus when we
look at our games today it's possible
also to play e6 that's a very popular
alternative but now we've transposed to
a Chafin ingen which is a you know a
completely different opening but yeah
it's very popular as well
now there's one popular alternative that
black can play here other than a five
and that's the move Knight to g4
immediately challenging this Knight and
now you'll see a lot of super
Grandmaster games that end like this
and then and then they repeat and then
right so then right here you go draw so
this is a lot of top level games so when
you're not in a competitive mood you
this is a common way to make a draw so
when you when you need to win your
tournament
you want your draw that's that's the way
to do it now if black is the one that
wants to keep playing for a win he can
consider playing e5 here and if if in
this position white is you know feeling
a little more ambitious he wants to keep
fighting the move he can play here is
Bishop to g5 what's an annoying pin on
the e pawn and play can get really crazy
really fast for example they can attack
your Bishop and they can go crazy on the
Kings side and expand and so this is a
common position and you know what is
black doing this is kind of crazy as any
creating a lot of weaknesses what's
going on yes this is a decent way to
play and the most common moves are
either Bishop e2 or h3 kicking this
night away if you play Bishop to e2
black is intending to play a move like
h5 he's serious about moving those pawns
over there but to show a funny blunder
what white is looking to do in this
position is reroute this Bishop he no
longer belongs here he should go back to
his natural diagonal so we'll play a bad
move we'll see why h3 is more common in
this position black has a nice winning
combination here
right Knight to e3 which is an excellent
move and it might just appear okay well
you're going to move your queen maybe
I'll grab your Bishop but black has an
even better move here and so this is why
I showed this position because there's
so many tactics like this when you play
the Sicilian so let's see so here's
who's the tactical genius in here you
are what is it
awesome yeah Bishop takes d4 which wins
some material the point is if Queen
takes even you see it right and so yeah
oops
that'd be a big mistake okay so you
can't play f3 here which okay so I play
people play h3 and we won't go too much
into this but it's nice to know that
this this line exists so alright we'll
get back to the main line here and we'll
be looking today at lines where they
don't play Knight to g4
which means we'll look at E 5 and now
the most common move is Bishop to b3
because you're not going in the way of
your pawns because you want to move
these guys and you want to checkmate
black what did I say I say Bishop to b3
yeah I don't know there's so many pieces
I don't know the names all of them come
on there's too many pieces all right
yeah Knight to b3 is the main line
Knight to f3 is definitely a relatively
nice way to play though it's a little
bit more positional while often Castle
kingside in these lines so we'll just
show some lines here and what white is
playing for is control over d5 that's
the that's the big thing and so there's
the big debate when you play the knight
Orff and you play the move e5 White's
going to try to say you know this is you
got this big weakness here eventually
I'll install a piece there it'll be
great forever and ever
but black is saying with this move well
I got my fair share of the center and
I'm going to get some really active
piece play and if ever I get to break
like this usually black will be better
so white has to be really careful and
yeah so what that's what Black's
compensation is it's active pieces
dynamic play and okay we'll just go a
few moves farther down the line here
and all right so yeah so again we see
this this common maneuver we're trying
to take one of the defenders of the d5
square but black can retreat here and
are this is a position that has occurred
several times and all right so what what
does black have four you know he allowed
this Knight here that's White's big
Trump but all right black gets some you
know active play he gets to bring his
knight out he can attack the bishop
sometimes he might think about playing
f5 and he's going to find some pretty
good squares for all of his pieces so
all in all that's that's an interesting
way to play but we're going to look at
the sharper move in this position which
is Knight to b3 with the attention of
checkmating your opponent okay and all
right we'll play a few just natural
developing moves so we can see sort of
the point and all right so this is
basically the starting position of
tonight's lecture so right what is going
on what are the plans again White's plan
is the simple and obvious you know upon
storms raw and you attacks all the
squares that's what white is playing for
and what is black going to do well he
also has pawns that he can use he can go
just lodge at night maybe he can just
Lodge the other one play b3 crash open
on the Queen side and all right maybe
he's going to put her a rook over here
sometimes we'll have the thematic
exchange sacrifice and it's a big race
who's going to checkmate who first all
right so this first game that we're
going to look at is a very nice victory
by white and I'm often very fond of the
games that happen here in st. Louis
because I'm watching him live I remember
what my emotions were when I was
watching the game and so this is a game
from the the Sinquefield Cup in 2015 so
this was a you know Carlsen versus
Wesley so and this was a very very nice
game
all right so we got the English attack
and all right so a little bit different
approach here he didn't just you know
develop his Bishop and castle he's
getting his pieces out he's going to
play b5 really quickly and all right so
we get such a position and all right and
yeah so here we go so now we're going to
see who can attack who faster and this
game is going to be an excellent example
of white controlling d5 he's even going
to sacrifice a pond just to make sure he
has a huge grip on d5 so the storm
begins and all right black gets to
attack first which is not necessarily
the most common line most people like to
castle with black but this also leads to
an interesting pawn structure so the
knight installs itself in d5 and now
black has the opportunity to take it and
change the pawn structure so the bishop
will take the pawn will take back and
all right now black is saying well I
don't have this weakness anymore and
white gets the claim well I got the two
bishops and we'll see white got a really
powerful attack in this game all right
this is a but this is blacks also main
idea he's going to try to win the d5
pawn now to take with the queen and
allow dis capture and now your move only
in this position and this position has
been seen several times and white tries
to get you know a little attack going
before black gets castled in practice
what is done you know pretty well in
these lines but the highest-rated game
saw nond winning with the black pieces
from this position so it's really double
edged and a lot of crazy stuff are going
to happen and you know taking the b4
pawn is really risky because you know
now the B file is open so sometimes bad
stuff will happen here but in this game
Carlsen took a different approach Knight
to a5 which means he's sacrificing this
pawn and okay you put your knight on the
same diagonal as a queen so so what's
going on you got to move your knight now
and that's what he did and all right why
did you sacrifice a pawn well again
we're going to see he's going to go for
control of d5 so after he takes
all right we got we got everybody here
looking at d5 and now the the novelty of
the game Bishop to c4 a very logical
move again just controlling the d5
square with everything that he's got
okay so white moves back and now
occasionally bad stuff can happen on
this diagonal so white has to be careful
like if he plays inaccurately black will
have this move which is a little bit
troublesome for him you know you don't
want this bishop to get active so the
move h4 was played all right so he's
just stopped in that move black gets on
with the attack and a nice move again
he's just shutting down the bishop on
this diagonal here all right and now
also interesting too he puts his Bishop
on d5 and black is at some point he's
going to take this bishop and then
White's going to be very very happy
because he's going to take with a knight
and he's going to get the dream position
the good night versus the bad Bishop all
right all right yes so this was also an
excellent idea how is white going to
continue his attack well he wants to
keep these pawns where they are so he's
instead gonna play f4 f5 if he gets a
chance you know he's going to keep
storming all the way down and open up
some files here so he does now indeed
take which i think is a bit of a mistake
you know you don't want to enter this
scenario with the Good Knight versus the
bad bishop so you know he's saying I'm
up a pawn though so what's more
important is it the positional
compensation or is it the material and
that's kind of what the argument is here
in this game so he moves the Queen out
of the way and yeah he gets on with it
yeah you really can't allow me to play
f5 because then you know I'm gonna play
off six so he had to play that five
himself and now white plays you know a
tempting move a goading move he says all
right put your pawn on e4 so black has a
passed pawn that's true but the position
with the pawns blocked is really going
to favor the guy with the night because
you know this guy gets better the more
this guy is shut down and at some point
he's going to get upon all the way to
eight
six and he's gonna you know try to get
his Queen on this diagonal and maybe
he'll get some you know attack going so
that's what he does and now he does not
move his knight you know so obviously
like a bad move would be you know
getting rid of your knight he just gets
on with it
so one question I have is what's
happening here didn't he did he just
blunder a piece what was white gonna
play in this position to Carlsen just
blunder a piece yeah yeah Queen b3 is
the idea and yeah we'll pick that guy up
next so he's not really threatening to
take the knight so said g6 and only now
does he play Queen to b3 threatening
some discovered checks so black has to
be careful so Rho kept seven blocks that
diagonal and now a really nice
positional move and the computer doesn't
find it till it's on depth 45 yeah I
studied this game alright
a for the ideas are we're keeping these
pawns here and yes nice to have this guy
on the light square he's got great
control of light squares and we'll see
we'll see what happens here okay
so black his only real hope here of
getting a decent position is to somehow
find a great square for this guy so will
he ever get out here and go somewhere
useful on this diagonal that's that's
part of the question and typical Carlsen
he puts the squeeze on here he doubles
his rooks and okay he gets ready so this
move is coming will the bishop re-emerge
and have a nice home well he does it so
what's going on here
why is a Carlsen allowed this what's
what's happening even if you move your
rook maybe he'll take your knight and
you know he's a pond up so what moved to
white play here and there's two right
answers so there's two good moves here
one of them is just simply to take the
spawn that's a good move but he chose a
different move which is also very good
Knight to c4 and all right you can take
my rook but now you're not defending the
a pond yes
with his rook that's true
blacks kind of happy because he got rid
of his bad bishop and even better he
took a rook so I don't know I'm going to
defend both of my pawns and now I'm up
material so this this is an idea and we
do you know we're thinking about
sacrificing stuff in this position but
he chose instead Knight takes a five
because now at least we're going to take
a look and we're going to get the
exchange back okay so he decided he's be
a little tricky
he in this position he didn't just take
the knight and if he ever enters this
endgame and it's you know Queen and rook
force Queen and rook boyd's pressure is
going to be really strong these you know
the queen is going to have excellent
chance on either one of these diagonals
for for a big attack so he needs to keep
the minor pieces on the board to have a
chance here and all right he's saying
well maybe your knight is a little bit
trapped in there so he had to protect it
and all right what's going on here can
can I just win a piece this wasn't
played but what would white play in this
position because if you do nothing I
just take your knight
and this is also pretty powerful you
know the knight can can come back here
with some threats and you know this
queen is thinking about sneaking in a
lot of bad stuff can happen here so you
don't get to trap the night
so instead tries a e3 will this pawn be
enough will this cause white enough
disturbance he's got to worry about this
guy all the time is he going to make it
down the board wait has a passed pawn
too so he pushes it and all right this
was the move that really lost it for for
black here his position was already very
bad but now it's the computer says it's
over it's over
but you had to play the right move here
so who can play like Carlsen yeah all
right and you made the same mistake that
I like to make he called UNITA bishop
you learned from the best
all right yeah so the knight can go to
d8 and yeah really bad stuff is going to
happen here so he he saved his rook
white was threatening checkmate so he
saved the rook and who knows I mean is
black going to get a powerful enough
attack here along the a file you got a
question okay they do have a check and
he played it and all right yeah this is
the best move but Carlsen didn't play it
well yeah that you're playing better
than the world champion because now what
does black do the problem is either way
you take this yeah you get into a lot of
trouble on this diagonal over here
because wherever wherever you go right I
munch up these guys so this would have
been the actually best way to play so
you're playing better than the world
champ but Knight to d4 also very strong
with the same sort of ideas and all
right he's just using his knight here to
control these squares all right but is
blacks attack gonna be fast enough he's
got some serious threats
what's white going to do all right so he
goes and picks up the pawn now this H
pawn is a huge advantage for white he
just has to not get checkmated okay so
he gave another check
and all right c3 so he made a little bit
of lift here all right so he's not
getting checkmated hooray
he might get checked but he didn't but
black is going to get checked again and
okay so black kind of has to defend
against Isis and Danny now we're gonna
fight you and me this is this is what it
happens let's do this all right
I bench more than you I work out more
than you we're gonna fight here so Danny
I can read his mind he's the type when
you get this position and you can win
the endgame Danny wants to trade the
Queens I guarantee it am i right well
you could also not trade Queens and you
would also win boo yeah so yeah Danny
and I have this conversation all the
time
and in positions like this when my queen
is better I like to keep the Queens on
the board because my queen is better
than your queen your king is a lot more
likely to get checkmated than my king
but you know even carlson makes mistakes
sometimes you know he plays like Danny
he traded the Queens yeah uh-uh
all right so we got this position and
all right what's this what's this Knight
planning to do I mean this this could be
a big threat taking here because if you
get two passers that could be really
really bad actually which is why he
chopped off the night here okay
and he took back with the rook what's
that Knights bishops I mean there's so
many pieces on the board it's like I
don't know all other names that's why I
need your help
you know all of the names of all the
pieces Wow hey um as a white blundered
here Oh is black just gonna go make a
Queen Europe can't stop me in time is
that true you could check and then
wherever the King goes he's in time yeah
but you got to be careful I mean King
upon and then your king and rook endings
they can be tricky so he has to make
sure he's there in time all right what
was okay sure you're playing like a like
Wesley so and that was played so we'll
see what happens
alright the king went over to go stop
the pond but gave a check and now we can
blunder we can blender now right and now
yeah you can't stop my pond so we could
blunder but he didn't he played a little
bit better than that so all right so
what's going to happen here is this guy
gonna be strong enough to win but all
right well the king get back in time in
the game he did not make it in time and
okay so he's getting ready yeah in this
position he's already threatening to to
go Queen so black has to stop it and see
for a really nice move it's hard to play
black here it's basically sub plane so
alright he had to move and yeah it's not
a lot of fun and here he he gave it up
the problem is he's not going to be able
to save this guy and if white ever gets
this pawn then you know the game is over
I got I got to pass pawns you know so
even if you go here I check you away and
then wherever you go I take this and
then that's game over yeah and I really
like this game I was fantastic watching
it live because in this game white gave
up a pawn even to get big control over
d5 and we saw a great example of having
the good night versus the bad bishop
that's the dream when you play this
position as white so now we look at a
game where black played a little bit
better and it's one of the most amazing
games ever played so even Danny will be
impressed all right this is the game
between Sergey karyakin in Vishwanath on
Anand it was played in 2006 in the
decorous tournament in Vikon say and we
get the same position here the knight
Orff the English attack and okay in this
game wait did I'm sorry black did castle
King King side and white one Queen side
so now we're going to have the race
which is more typical of what happens in
this position so here he comes
and here comes black so that the race is
on and so white gets to attack up piece
first and I really like
recommending these lines sort of for for
younger players that are strong enough
to understand openings because these
kinds of positions really teach you a
lot about chess you you're attacking
them they're attacking you you need to a
balanced attack and defense and you know
playing really accurately it kind of
teaches you that when they make a threat
you want to be trying to play an even
stronger threat so this really helps you
know people that are just learning chess
and you know young players alike so it's
it's good we don't have to move our
knight and so he didn't play in here
this is it you know also a move but yeah
so usually we get the same pawn
structure that we saw in the last game
after this and then you're just careful
not to lose this night and this is a
playable line but instead we saw a much
more aggressive move
b4 so we got both people attacking
people but the problem for white is you
can't just go oh I get to take you first
because now at the end of this line here
you take the Queen with check so what
has to be careful and what to do with
the night
well you went to E - that's a nice safe
Square and now it's your turn where
you're going to put your knight and okay
he went back and okay to discuss why he
didn't go to the side in this position
now white gets a really easy attack you
can put the night on g3 and opening the
H file is just about the worst thing you
can do in these kinds of positions it's
really easy to be white with an open H
file because yeah it looks like you're
gonna get checkmate it pretty quickly
you know you don't want to open the H
file so he has to go back and it's not
looking very good actually we'll flip
the board
we'll get black a little bit of respect
you like that Danny you happy now so now
is everybody confused like whoa
what's happening now all right so f4 was
played his intention is obviously just
to play a 5 and maybe he's going to trap
the bishop or force the bishop to trade
itself for a knight now it's yeah it's
not really advised that you take this
pawn because okay let's see you know
when the Knights going to take back this
bishops going to find a really nice
diagonal
and alright what's going to get a lot of
activity and the open F file isn't the
best for black yeah okay
and we'll see it we'll see what happens
here so black instead he gets on he
pushes his pawn and here it is
so the Bishop's trapped is he going to
trade for the night or is black going to
find something more complicated and
that's what happens in all of these
lines you know where they're attacking
us we're attacking them it's you know
it's very crazy and dynamic play so he
attacked the night instead and so he's
saying all right you've taken my bishop
I take your knight and you know things
are looking pretty good for me so he
instead moved his knight but not not two
of the safest square he went to the most
complicated square you could put your
knight on the worst square possible and
then somebody will go to your board and
say how did you get your night to a one
I thought that was impossible and then
you know after you take this your Bishop
is not going to get trapped in there and
what blacks can have an excellent game
so instead you know he moved his knight
so black took it this you know he just
sacrificed a piece what was the point
what's going on here all right and so
black decides he pushes so if you just
take this you're going to lose because
I'm going to make a queen you know you
can even you can take with check but
I'll take back and this is unstoppable
yeah for times sake we can't do any more
questions hmm okay
so instead he yeah moved his king over
and black took we'll check Knight takes
which is important and we'll see why and
now we're trying to understand black in
what should he do his Bishop is attacked
well here he has an excellent move maybe
one you you wouldn't consider when you
first look at the position but Bishop to
b3 so he's giving up his Bishop in order
to open the a file so this is the the
key way to get access to the King and
the knight really must block but let's
blunder because blundering is fun that's
something people can relate to all right
if I go here instead and I'm us alright
I'll go get your pawn put my knight in
the center I'm doing great black now has
a winning move who can do it
it's a it's a nice little tactic here
yeah rope 2h a check excellent and when
you come in yeah the point is we we get
our queen in here and you can give your
queen up to stop getting mated or you
can get check mated you know it's your
choice
so what yet white either loses material
there or he gets mated so yeah it's
important that you put the knight on a
three and you know you got this this
access here so we got to shut it down
okay and so what did what did black play
here yeah he moved his rook or no sorry
in a in this position he moved his rook
and nowadays it's slightly more popular
to put the rook on a four this is still
all theory not only are you you know
putting pressure on this pawn here but
white often wants to play the move Queen
to b4 in these lines and you stop that
from happening okay so instead rook a
five was played black's big idea here is
alright he's going to put a queen on the
a file she's gonna be eyeballing this
we're thinking about some exchange
sacrifices on occasion and now white
plays the losing move he should play
Queen to b4 but he went one Square too
short and now this is why I really like
this game there's a fantastic sequence
here it doesn't look like black is just
winning you know it's it's really hard
to to figure it out
blitzie so he first moves his queen he
attacks the the e4 pawn white defends
and now the craziest move you've ever
seen so at home you really want to pause
your video here and try to work this out
because you know it's really crazy move
this about to happen you can test your
attacking ability how can we make
inroads here to the king and it's more
complicated than it might seem
yes
okay oh I'll take back okay
now Danny Machuca to move in blunder
with white you can do it right excellent
good blunder yeah I take this and here
right I knew you could do it Danny I
knew you could do it all right right
yeah so instead I mean white plays here
and now you got nothing all right
he agrees yeah you got nothing so that
wasn't played so we'll give some some
hints here what you really need to do is
you know get this Knight to move away
because then you'd be looking good which
means you probably need to put your
knight here
the problem of course is he won't take
with a knight he'll take with the Queen
which means you need to get the Queen
out of there which means you might need
to put a rook here on the C file but
there's a knight in your way I mean this
is a complicated problem so what did
black play here you got it now
so yeah if you have you figured it out
so here it here it is he played the
fantastic move Knight to c7 and you're
like what he's isn't that piece hanging
so white took it and all right
what's up so what's going on now how
should we continue continue being
brilliant don't be half really in here
you got to be really brilliant so all
right we want a piece how to continue
and you might be thinking all right
maybe we take this Knight
all right all right maybe maybe we're in
now but in such positions you really got
to be careful and understand the
resources the white has to defend here
you know he needs to worry about this
threat and he can consider even just
trying to trade the Queen's which is now
hard to avoid so you got to be really
careful it's it's not quite that it's an
even more brilliant move he sacrificed a
bishop so white took it and now White's
up to pieces
so black you better checkmate right and
again this isn't the way forward we
still have this this
resource here and now it's even better
because I took all your pieces so we've
got to be be pretty careful here you
better play the right move
you're either about to be the biggest
genius ever or the biggest blunder ever
you just gave away all your pieces so
which will it be
and what did black play in this position
this one I'm sure somebody can find this
one all right the only guy that ever
raises his hand you yeah Knight to c4
excellent all right
you never know which way is which in
this game I just keep flipping it on you
yeah okay so yeah it's tough being white
here it's definitely not easy
so what decided yeah I'm going to get
checkmated so I better check mate you
first that's your only chance and you
played the move g6 now if you're a
little too careless with black you might
not be the one check reading your
opponent so let's take this because it's
a blunder and let's take this because
it's a blunder now white how is he going
to checkmate you
it might seem alright innocent you know
you got your one check all right
fantastic I'll go in the corner but now
white can kind of get out of some of his
trouble by making something Danny would
you make a queen or a rook your chess
artist rook okay and then we'll take
this and why can even consider sacking
the Queen and getting the bishop to this
diagonal so just kind of like I did in
the other variation and black should
still be a little bit better but this is
really complicated and not easy to win
so you get another really sharp position
they'll be really tough so black has to
be careful all right
ah alright let's let's go back so in
this move he decided he would take the
pawn once white takes back and now the
threats aren't the same so now he gets
to take here and all right black is very
close to checkmating and all right white
had some checks he's got a couple tricks
here he gets the first one in and then
both legal moves here are fine for black
they actually both win but all right
this one seems to make a lot of sense
here white checked by making your name
and okay and it's funny you can actually
survive if you just like if you move
your king somewhere like most King moves
are see driving which is kind of funny
you know it seems like you shouldn't but
even if you check me like a bunch of
times like somehow black still wins so
that's kind of funny but he yeah let's
see you boop-boop night check he took it
and all right so white was able to
distract one of the rooks that's kind of
you know crucial to his success here but
what does white have now he took the
rook and alright so we might your first
instinct might be well don't take the
Queen but yeah you're going to get in
another scenario where this bishop comes
back to defend and it's not very easy to
win you're probably still winning but
it's this is tougher than it has to be
instead black decided to just go
checkmate white because that's that's a
pretty good idea so he gave this check
the king is going for a little jog here
White's most testing move is probably
just to go back but then you know the
black Queen gets into the game and you
know life life is pretty tough to be be
white here if you just go back we can
yet even grab this Queen now Cupid and
yeah it's a little bit different with
this guy here because now I just need to
I need to find a way in here and this is
probably White's best chance to survive
but he decided to go up the board which
is really scary and now he's getting
checkmated and it gives me another
chance you know to tell people what I I
think in positions like this when you
have a lot of time on your clock and
you're in this position you really want
to mate as absolutely best as you can if
it's mating forward you want to mate in
four moves you don't want to mate in
five or six because this is about to be
the greatest game of all time and so if
it was mating four and he made it in
five I couldn't show you the game it
would just be terrible like it's like
it's showing me art and like you painted
the Mona Lisa at the very end you're
like the eyes on Mel dot dot you know
you're about to make the greatest thing
ever so it's got to look good at the
very end and black played perfectly
white is getting checkmated here and
yeah he gave it up here if here where's
the checkmate you can do it
ah missed it by one who are you gonna go
here
okay what's the move what's the move
yeah say it right Queen to c2 I'm really
glad you didn't say rook here check I'd
be so angry you ruined the masterpiece
and just be like this is the worst game
you've ever played I wouldn't be showing
it yeah you got to make one when it's
mate in one and okay if I go this way I
just did it
look look I'm Peter let me do it I did
it I can't do it look I did it the
computer accept it well let me make it
legal moves yeah I did I did some magic
and I went back in time so I could I
said oh I got checkmated over there
maybe I'll escape over here but alright
so this is the last position here what's
the fastest way to mate come on people
that aren't raising their hands come on
come on dude is this beneath you okay
okay alright are we got our all-star you
could do it get us the last check the
end of the day all right you're gone all
right all right you have a faster way if
you don't mate into here you're ruining
the canvas right you don't ruin it here
who can do it
yeah bro k2 oh man I'm in check right
excellent
so I'd be checkmate and yes so this game
is really excellent not only was it you
know fantastic display of tactics and
the ability to attack your opponent but
yeah it shows kind of the
resourcefulness and creativity that you
need when you play the night off you
know you always got to be thinking about
these really really creative ways to
attack because when both sides are
attacking you often want to sacrifice
the material and checkmate your opponent
Oh